CBS News senior Global Affairs
contributor Ian Bremmer is with us he is
president of the Eurasia Group Ian good
morning with you key question what is on
the table as they're talking about
offering something brand-new to the
North Koreans I think Trump is going
with no preconditions whatsoever so it
would include significant economic
benefits a declaration of the end of the
Korean War we've already heard about the
potential of the u.s. putting an embassy
in Pyongyang and even the disposition of
US troops on the ground in South Korea I
think would be open to discussion if in
return they were able to get verifiable
denuclearization
I think everyone understands that's
either an incredibly high bar or a
completely implausible if we talk about
denuclearization help us figure out some
of the component parts so North Korea is
unlikely to say okay tomorrow it's all
going away so it's about inspections how
fast they can happen when they can
happen can they be so-called snap
inspections and over what time period is
that right is that what we should look
for sure but again I mean the idea that
everything that has gotten the United
States the table is the fact that they
have a nuclear arsenal and I think the
reality is what the North Koreans could
do for the Americans goes back to what
was unacceptable in a red line for Trump
when all of this started which is the
ability of the North Koreans to actually
hit the United States with an ICBM and a
payload on top of it right that's
something that the North Koreans could
give to the United States they've
already unilaterally suspended their
nuclear test and their ICBM tests if
they were willing to say we're gonna
dump our ICBM program we won't be able
to hit the continental United States
that's a good initial measure and
something I think that could be a part
of an initial good so you're saying they
would keep some kind of nuclear program
it just wouldn't be able to hurt the
United States and that might be a
sufficient middle ground I think it's
very clear that the word
denuclearization will be thrown around
directly by both Trump and Kim jong-un
and if there's a joint statement they
will both find a way to include it in
that statement I think we should be
careful in how we read that right yeah I
get your take on the G summit at the end
of the g7 summit you know there seem to
be Bruce feelings on both sides
you know the Trump administration is
saying that the president was respond
to Justin Trudeau when he came and
called him dishonest and what do you
make of that in the language that's used
well I mean the good news is that I
don't think the horrible g7 summit is
going to affect the North Korea's coming
up but this was the worst foreign policy
outing the Trump has had since he became
president it's the worst g7 summit since
they started back in 1975 and for me it
was kind of the geopolitical equivalent
of the Comey firing right
it was Trump unable to control his
emotional impulses and doing something
that I am sure felt very satisfying at
the time he was forced to go he didn't
want to attend the summit as advisors
all said you have to be there he shows
up late he leaves early he cancels his
direct meeting with Makran and the
entire time he's clearly seething
bristling and petulant but he's on good
behavior
finally he leaves and he says that's it
I'm gonna blow it up and I'm sure that
sending that out against Trudeau
America's closest ally felt really good
at the time it really damages an
important long-term relation but Annie
said he was responding to something that
Trudeau had said about him what did
shudos say that was so egregious nothing
that he hadn't said already Trudeau was
very careful not to insult the president
personally he did say that the Canadians
were not going to just sit and take it
in terms of the American tariffs that
there would be retaliation that's
exactly what he had said on Meet the
Press the week before and in other
public statements this was not about
what Trudeau said this is about Trump's
feelings and and when Trump feels a
certain way he is not to be told
otherwise by his handlers and I think he
showed very clearly you can tell me to
do whatever you want I'm my own man on
my own president and again at the time
it felt great but this is pretty grave
damage to the most important allies
around the world who are not going to
form a g6
they have note they're not unified they
have no ability to get together on other
issues the Europeans the Japanese the
Canadians know but they don't trust the
Americans Trump said that the
relationship with the allies was a 10
maybe out of a hundred but the reality
is that the relationship with the United
States is reasonably uncertain right now
the individual relationship with Trump
of those allies
as bad as it could be it's close to a
zero all right Ian Bremmer thank you for
joining this morning